ああああ
ああ
祖父が被爆者だとしたのは私が6歳のころ
ですそれは二重被爆者だということを祖父
はその時に語ってくれたんですけれども
原爆や戦争について私が祖父にあの教えて
欲しいと言ったところがん
6歳のことでした
祖父の戦争中の職業は
三菱長崎造船所で船の設計技師をしてい
ました
祖父は造る船がなかったのであの小型の
船舶おかえりをしてそれを戦争に使える
ようにあのまあ設計をしていたようです
けれども詳しく私にはを教えてくれません
ですたたその後でホンレイシュルしている
のでそれで知ったんですけれども
まあ三菱で働いていました
祖父が2巻被曝したというのは本当に
大きなことなんですが孫の私としてはまず
あの被曝をしたっていうことはどうしてか
ということそして2度原爆に遭ったという
ことはなぜなのかということを疑問に思っ
ていますそれはの皆さん衝撃的でそして
まあは同情してくださいますけれども
なぜっていうことを常に考えていかなけれ
ばいけないしそこからまたあのいろいろな
形であの原爆や被ばくというものを自分
なりに捉えていたなければいけないかなと
思っています
祖父はの
まあ被爆後アメリカ軍の通訳そして
まあ英語の教師をしていたわけですけれど
も三菱を解雇されてすぐにできる仕事が
メリカ軍の通訳だったその2浴をしながら
アメリカ人の兵士と友情を育むことによっ
て
まあ人間らしさを取り戻したと言ってい
ました
皮膚の色が違っても目の色が違っても同じ
人間なんだから
んまぁ分かり合えるっていうふうに私は
聴いて育ったのでその思いで今活動ができ
ているというのは祖父が私の教えてくれた
ことかなと思っています
被爆者というのは男女問わず
偏見や差別がありました女性は結婚でき
ないこともあった私の祖父も祖母もそして
叔父も被爆者ですけれどもまぁうちは沖縄
でなくなっていますですから沖縄広島長さ
秋というふうに私たちは千浪に翻弄された
被爆者の家族なんですが私が思うのはまあ
母はあの被爆2世になりますけれども
白血球が安定していませんしまぁ小さい頃
から話がてで入院していたとですから各が
人間に与える影響というものは代々続いて
いくものだ足
体を蝕んでいくんだと思いますが心に傷も
をいます子ですからあの被爆者家族として
話ができることは
あ伝えていきたいそういうふうに思って
ます
私は日本人に期待することはまずその加害
の責任をきちんと理解をして認めること
そして
アメリカ人はきちんとアード原爆に対して
あの事実を知ることが大事だと思います
加害と被害というものはどちらにもあると
いうことそれを前て話し合いをしないと一
歩通行になりますし
憎しみからは何も生まれないと思います
そして私にはアメリカのに友人もいますね
あり b ざーがいるんですけれどもまあ
ペットでこちらで話しさせていただいたり
b さんは
あの長崎に前に来てくれますし
私たちはまあアメリカと日本で核廃絶を
訴えているわけですけれども
まあ手を繋いでで心をつないで何か発信
できればいいなというふうに話しています
なあ憎しみだけをあの表に出すのではなく
てそこから
一歩先に何かあのを進めていくことが
できるのではないかと思いますしアメリカ
とは日本が手を携えて世界に発信すれば
より大きな発信力になると思うので
アメリカそして日本というあの被爆した国
そして原爆を飛ばした国ということで
から合わせて発信することが大事かなと
思っています
よりよい関係を築くということはお互いを
知るということが一番大事だと思うんです
ねですからその過去にどういう戦争の歴史
がをたがあったかっていうことをまず知る
って言うこととどういう風な思い出あいき
ているかっていうこともし
るっていうことがあのまず大事かなと思い
ます
つないでくれたのはあの二重被爆の映画を
作られた稲塚秀隆監督なんですけれども
それからありがあの自宅に会いに来てくれ
ましたねはぁと話して記録を取りたいと
いうことでまぁ撮影終わりはしに来たん
ですけれどもその時にあの話す機会があっ
て
私たちからは憎しみ約感じないとでもう
やはりあの緊張してコアがこわばってまし
たしきた時はあの大丈夫かなというふうに
思ったんですけれども話し合うということ
がアドばかり合うということが一番大事な
んだなってその時に思いましたし
ありのあのおじいさまはきのこ雲の上で
被爆してで私の祖父は
したで被爆してますであの
2人の戦争や原爆の体験っていうものは
あの
まあそれぞれの国それぞれのまあ宿命が
ありますけれどもマニングがあったりとか
大義があったりとかそういうことでそう
いう関係になっていますが私たちは孫の
世代ですから
ここから何か2人で書いていけるのでは
ないかということお話していますですから
その
何か二人でできることもうこれからは
もっと考えて発信していけたらなぁと思い
ます
核を保有するということはそれだよリスク
も伴うわけですよね例えば
ん人為的ミスがあったり
あののないとは限らないですし
まずその環境破壊につながるそして核実験
で世界中の人々が被爆者になる可能性も
ある
それを踏まえて
まぁ持っているのでしょうけれども
人類を存続するということで考えればまあ
放棄をするという勇気もう一番大事かなと
思いますそれではなかったらやはり人間と
いうものは生きていけないですから格闘
人間というものはは共存できないっていう
風に私の祖父も入ってますし私もそう思っ
ていますですから手放すという勇気が一番
大事かなと思います